so before we get started I'm just gonna
say a brief note about the logistics for
the midterm we're gonna be split across
two rooms the room you're in it depends
on your
normal Stamford ID whatever the first
letter is will send an email out about
this to confirm it but we're gonna be in
either gates b1 or Cubberley auditorium
and it depends on the first few the
first letter of your Stanford ID in
addition you're allowed to have one page
of notes typed or written as fine one
sided we have any other questions about
the midterm okay we'll reach out to us
on Piazza if you have any questions
about the midterm what we'll do today is
we're gonna split we're gonna go finish
up the rest of policy gradient so in
terms of where we are in the class right
now we are almost done with policy
search we're gonna have the midterm on
Wednesday Monday is a holiday and then
we'll also be releasing the last
homework this week which will be over
policy search and so we're going to have
policy search and then we're gonna have
the project that's the remaining sort of
main assignments for the term and then
we're gonna be getting into fast
exploration and sort of fast
reinforcement learning after we come
back from the midterm so I wanted to
make sure to get through policy search
today because you're gonna have the
assignment release later this week so
we'll spend hopefully around like 2025
minutes on policy search and then we're
gonna do a brief review before we get
into the midterm about the midterm
material somebody have any questions oh
and just a friendly reminder to please
say your name whenever you ask a
question because it helps me remember it
also helps everybody else learn your
names as well alright so where we were
is that for the last couple lectures
we've been starting to talk about policy
based reinforcement learning where we're
specifically trying to find a
parametrized policy to learn how to make
good decisions in the environment and so
just like what we saw with value
function approximation and what you're
doing with atari for our policy
parameterization we're gonna assume
there's some vector parameters we can
represent policies by things like
softmax or by a deep neural network and
then we're gonna want to be able to take
gradients of these types of policies in
order to learn a policy that has a high
value so we introduced sort of the
vanilla policy gradient algorithm where
the idea is that you start off you
initialize your policy in some way and
you also have some baseline and then
across different iterations you run
your current policy and the goal is work
by running these outs that we're gonna
be able to estimate the gradient so
we're gonna be doing this part to
estimate the gradient of our policy at
the currents we want to get sort of DB D
theta with respect to our current policy
so what we talked about is that you
would run out trajectories from your
current policy so use your policy to
execute in the environment you would get
state action rewards next state and it's
X and X rewards and then you would look
at returns and advantage estimates which
compared your returns to a baseline good
refat your baseline and then you could
update your policy and so this was sort
of the most vanilla policy gradient
algorithm we talked about and then we
started saying that there's a number of
different choices that we're making in
this algorithm and almost all sort of
policy gradient based algorithms are
gonna form follow this type of formula
so in particular we are making a
decision of sort of estimating some sort
of return or targets often we were
picking a baseline and then we had to
make some decision about after we
compute the gradient how far along the
gradient do we go so this is sort of
helping us to determine how far do we
move on our gradient so for the first
part we talked about how do we estimate
sort of the value of where we are right
now that we're going to be using to try
to estimate our gradient and we talked
about the fact that the most vanilla
thing that we could do is just roll out
the policy and look at the returns and
that this was really similar to what
we'd seen in Monte Carlo estimates so we
could do that we could get sort of an
estimate of the value function by just
rolling out the policy for one episode
but that was just like what we saw a
Monte Carlo an unbiased estimator but
high variance and so we talked about how
we could play all the sorts of we use
also the same tools as what we've been
doing in the past to try to balance
between bias and variance
so in particular we talked about how we
could introduce bias using bootstrapping
and function approximation just like
what we saw in TDM see and just like
what we talked about with value function
approximation so we could repeatedly see
these same sorts of ideas at the fact
that we're trying to understand what the
value is of a particular policy and when
we're estimating that value then we can
trade-off between getting sort of
unbiased estimators of how good
decisions are versus biased estimators
that might allow us to propagate
information more quickly and allow us to
learn to make better decisions faster we
also talked about the fact that there
are actor critic methods that both
maintain an explicit parametrized
representation of the policy and a
parametrized representation of the value
function but the thing that we really
started getting into last time is to say
well both you know there are all these
sort of existing techniques that we know
of to try to estimate these targets and
estimate the value function but then
there's this additional question of how
far do we move along the gradient so
once we estimate the gradient of the
policy we need to figure out how far
along that gradient do we go in terms of
computing a new policy and the reason we
argued this was particularly important
in reinforcement learning versus
supervised learning is that whatever
step we take whatever new policy we look
at is going to determine the data we get
next and so it was a particularly
important for us to think about how far
along do we want to go on our gradient
to get a new policy and one desirable
property we were talking about is how do
we ensure monotonic improvement so what
we would like here is we'd really like
monotonic improvement that's our goal
and we talked about wani monotonic
improvement which was not guaranteed and
dqn or a lot of other algorithms because
in a lot of high stakes domains like
finance customers patients you might
really want to ensure that the new
policy or deploying is expected to be
better at least an expectation before
you deploy it so we talked about wanting
this but there's this big problem that
we don't have data from the new policies
that we're considering
and we don't want to try out all the
possible next policies because some of
them might be bad and so we want to try
to use our existing data to figure out
how do we take a step and determine a
new policy that we think is going to be
good so in particular our main goal for
policy gradients is to try to find a set
of policy parameters that maximize our
value function and the challenge is that
we currently have access to data that
was gathered with our current policy
which we're going to call pi old
paradigm tries by asset if they does
that we can also denote data old and and
throughout policy the policy gradient
lectures I have been sort of going back
and forth between talking about policies
and talking about betas but it's good
just to remember that there's sort of
this direct mapping between PI and theta
you know there's four each for a policy
it's exactly defined by a set of
parameters so whether we're talking
about policies or we're talking about
parameters those are referring to
exactly the same thing so the challenges
is that we have data from our current
policy which has some set of parameters
and we want to predict the value of a
different policy and so this is a
challenge with off policy learning so
what we're talking about last time is
how do we express the value of a policy
in terms of stuff that we do know and we
talked about how we could write it down
in terms of an advantage over the
current policy so if we think about a
value being parameterised by a new set a
new policy with a new set of theta tilde
parameters it's equal to the value of
another policy parameterize by a set of
theta plus the expected advantage so we
can write that as the distribution of
states that we would expect to get to
under the new policy times the advantage
we would get under the old policy if we
were to follow the new policy
and the reason what what we're trying to
do in this case just to sort of keep us
thinking about what the main goal is
here is what we're trying to do is
figure out a way to do policy gradient
where we're guaranteed to have monotonic
improvement or our new policy is going
to be guaranteed to be better than our
old policy but we want to do this
without actually trying out our new
policy so we're trying to reexpress what
the value is of a new policy in terms of
quantities we have access to so what do
we have access to we have access to
existing samples from the current policy
and we want to use those and the returns
we've observed in order to estimate the
value of a new policy before we deploy
it that's kind of where we're trying to
get to and we noticed here that maybe
you know we can have access to an
explicit form of a new policy that's
like whatever new parameters were
considering putting into our neural
network and we could imagine estimating
the advantage function but we don't know
the state distribution under the new
policy because that would require us
actually to run it so what we talked
about is let's just define a new
objective function which is just a
different objective function might be
good might be bad I'm gonna argue too
it's a good it's good but this right now
is just a quantity that we can optimize
so the quantity that we can optimize
here we're gonna call that sort of this
new objective function and it is gonna
be a function of the previous value so
here remember this is always equal to
direct mapping between Thetas and PI's
so we're gonna just say it looks like
the objective function we just talked
about which really was the value of the
new policy but we don't know what that
stationary weighted distribution is of
states under the new policy so we're
just gonna substitute in the stationary
distribution under the current policy
now in general this is not going to be
so it's not going to be equal to your
new policy distribution the only time
you're going to get the same state
distribution under two policies is
generally if they're identical
occasionally you can get the same state
distribution under two different
policies but then that means they have
the same value so in general we're going
to expect
but these going to be different but
we're gonna ignore that for now we're
just going to say this is an objective
function this is something we can
optimize and the nice thing about this
is that we have samples from the current
policy so we can imagine just using
those samples to estimate this
expectation the thing that I also want
us to note here is that this is just
this new objective function called L if
you have evaluate the objective function
L at the current policy so if you plug
in your old policy into your objective
function it's exactly equal to the value
of your current policy so the second
term becomes zero because the advantage
of the existing policy over the existing
policy is zero so this objective
function is exactly equal to the value
of the old policy if you evaluate it the
old policy and in other cases is for new
policies can be something different
guess how is this similar to important
standpoint you're asked how is this
similar to important sampling if we were
going to do important well it's
different in a number of ways I'm an
important sampling what we tend to do is
we re weight the distribution that we
want by the distribution that we have in
this case we're looking and we normally
do that on a per state level I in this
case we are looking at the stationary
distribution over States there's
actually a really cool paper that just
came out in nerves like a month ago 2018
wittily Hong Li and some other
colleagues that looked at how would you
reweighed stationary distributions to
try to get off policy estimates of the
value function and so to try to directly
reweighed what like Mew PI would be
versus Mew PI tilde so we're not doing
that here there's some really nice ideas
and that that could help really reduce
the variance and long horizon problems
in this case we're just substituting so
we're ignoring the difference we're not
doing important sampling we're just
pretending that the distribution of
states that we get to is exactly the
same it's not but we're gonna show that
this is going to end up being a useful
lower about
- what we want - what we actually want
optimized okay
so you might say if you take this
objective function which might be good
might not be good if we optimize with
respect to it do we have any guarantees
on whether the new value function that
we get if we optimize with respect to
this wrong objective function is better
than the old value function because
remember that's where we're trying to go
- we don't really care what we're
optimizing what we care about is that
the resulting value function we get out
is actually better than the old value
function so last time I said that if you
have the mixture policy which blend
between your current policy and a new
policy so let's say you have a PI old
and you have some other policy
I haven't said how you get it but just
say you have some other policy and that
defines your new policy so with
probability 1 minus alpha you take the
same action is you used to with
probability alpha you take a new action
in this case you can guarantee a lower
bound on the value of the new policy so
the value of the new policy is greater
than or equal to this objective function
we have here - this particular quantity
so that says that if you optimize with
respect to this weird L objective
function you can't actually get bounds
on how good your new policy is so that
seems promising
but in general we're not going to want
to just consider mixture policies okay
so what this theorem says is that for
any stochastic policy not just this
weird mixture you can get a bound on the
performance by using this slightly
strange objective function so in
particular define the distance of total
variation as follows so D TV between two
policies so am i using a dot there to
denote that there's there's a number of
different actions that the policies are
denoting a probability distribution over
actions this is equal to the max over
all a the distance between the
probability that each of the two
policies put on that action so it's
giving us
of a maximum difference in what's the
probability of an action under one
policy versus the other policy and then
we can do let's see we can do D max of
total variation by taking the max of
that quantity over all states so it's
essentially saying over all states
what's the biggest difference that the
two policies give over a particular
action so where do they most differ and
then what this theorem says is that if
you have that quantity in general we're
not gonna be able to evaluate that but
what that's saying is that if you know
what that quantity is then you can
define that if you use this objective
function L that the new value of your
policy is at least the objective
function you compute minus this quantity
it's a function of the distance of total
variation the max distance of total
variation so this gives us some
confidence that if we were to optimize
with respect to the objective function L
then we can get a bound on the value
function now this distance this Max or
the total variation distance isn't
particularly easy to work with so we can
use the fact that the square of it is
upper bounded by the KL divergence and
then get a new bound which is a little
bit easier to work with that looks at
the KL divergence between the two
policies and we again get this similar
bound okay so why is this useful so what
I've told you right now is that we have
this new objective function if we use
this new objective function we could in
principle get this lower bound on the
performance of the new policy so how do
we use this to ensure that we want to
get monotonic improvement so the goal is
monotonic improvement we want to have
the V of Pi I plus 1 is greater than or
equal to V of PI I as our goal so I have
iterations we want that the new policy
that we deploy is actually better than
the policy we had before so how we're
going to do this so what we're gonna say
is first we have this objective function
here this lower bound objective function
and what we're going to define is that
mi of Pi I is equal to L of Pi I
hi so I'm just copying the equation from
the previous previous slide - for
epsilon gamma divided by 1 minus gamma
squared DK l max of pi I so this is the
lower bound that's what we just defined
on the previous slide so what we said
here is that the value of our new policy
so this is equal to this M function I've
defined so we've said that the new value
is going to be at least as good as this
lower bound so we're gonna say V of I
plus 1 it's going to be equal to M I of
Pi I plus 1 which is equal to L PI I
this one just writing out what the
definition is here and again what we're
trying to do here is get to the point
where we're confident that we can get
something that's better than our old
value function now the thing that I want
to now look at is well what is if we
were to evaluate the lower bound at the
current policy what would that be so
let's look at mi of PI I so that's going
to be equal to L PI I of Pi I I'm just
plugging it into this equation up there
- for epsilon gamma minus gamma squared
DK L max of hi I pi so why is this nice
well this is nice because the KL
divergence between two identical
policies is 0 because these are exactly
the same this is equal to 0 so now this
is just equal to L PI I of Pi I but what
I told you before is that if we go back
a few slides to what the definition is
of Pi I L of Pi I is that if you
evaluate it at the current policy
just equal to the value of that policy
so if we evaluate this objective
function at the current policy it's just
the same as the value of the current
policy so now if we go back here this is
just equal to be a PI I okay so what
does this say this says that if I want
to look at how my I put my the value of
my I plus one policy looks compared to
the value of my old policy we know
that's greater than or equal to M I of
Pi I plus one so because we've said that
the via we knew from this theorem that
the new value of the policy is greater
than or equal to this lower bound we
computed so it's greater than equal to M
I pious plus 1 minus M I of PI I so what
does this say this says that if your new
value function has a better lower bound
than your old value function you have
monotonic improvement so if this is
greater than zero then monotonic
improvement which means that if you
optimize with respect to this lower
bound and you can evaluate that quantity
and your new lower bound is higher than
your old lower bound then your value has
to be better so we can guarantee
monotonic improvement yes so just to
clarify so for these value comparisons
are we implicitly considering as an
infinity norm in terms of saying one is
better yes generally yeah I think I mean
they probably go through with l squared
too but yeah question is whether or not
we're always defining this with respect
to L infinity norm almost always I there
certainly is some analysis particularly
when we get into function approximation
which looks at an l2 norm but most of
this is all with respect to an L
infinity norm which means that when
we're looking at this for example we're
looking at ensuring that for all states
the value of those states is at least as
good as the previous value of the
state's yes so the claim was if our
lower bound improves that it must be the
case that what is the lower bound of
let's also be improving right is so
there's never a case where for example
you lower by my
proved even though the actual value of
the policy evaluated decreases it seems
like that's right so when this is what
this is asking about so have you know
this lower bound and what that relates
to the actual value what this is stadion
is that if you improve your tular like
if you have a lower bound of your
existing policy and you get a new lower
bound with through some new policy and
that new lower bound is higher then your
lower bound until one that you're
guaranteed to be improving so this is
what guarantees so this is assuming you
can solve this but if you if you could
get this lower if you optimize with
respect to this lower bound quantity
because when you plug in the lower bound
for the current policy under that that's
exactly equal to the value of that
policy then you're guaranteed to be
improving because you're basically
saying here's my lower here's my
existing value I have something whose
lower bound is better than my existing
value and so I know my new thing has to
be better changes depending on the great
one I might ask us about this I so note
this that your lower bound is in terms
of epsilon epsilon is a max over all
states and actions of your advantage in
principle you could evaluate this
pertain if you had a discrete state in
action space in practice that's
something that you would not want to do
this
I view this part is sort of saying this
is formally if you could evaluate this
laravel and what we're gonna do now is
talk about a more practical algorithm
which tries to take this guarantee of
conservative policy improvement and
actually make it practical in terms of
quantities that are a little bit easier
to compute because that's right yeah in
general it would be very hard to
evaluate this as this epsilon that you
could take upper or lower bounds on it
but you won't generally know what this
epsilon is and note that this as just
pointing out this epsilon is dependent
on the policy so all right but this is
pretty cool so it means that you can do
this guaranteed improvement this is a
form of mineral mineralization
maximization it's this nice idea
they're saying you can have this new
lower bound is guaranteed to be better
than the value of your current policy so
you can get this sort of conservative
monotonic improving policy all right so
I just I want to make sure we have
enough time to go through some of the
midterm review but I want to briefly
talk about how we would make this
practical particularly because trust
region policy optimization is an
extremely popular policy gradient
algorithm so I think it's useful for you
guys just to be aware of you some of you
might use it in some of your projects we
won't cover it and I won't be a
mandatory part of the homework or on the
midterm but I think it's just a useful
idea to be familiar with so again if we
look at sort of what this objective
function was that we just discussed we
said we had this ell function and then
we turned it into a lower bound by
subtracting off this constant that might
be hard for us to compute and so what we
do in this case is we take this constant
here and we turn it into a hyper
parameter so you could turn it into a
constant C but the problem wall always
is that even if you could compute this
often we don't know what this is but
even if you could compute it or computer
bound on it generally if we use this we
would take very small step sizes so
intuitively this is because you know
it's often very hard to extrapolate far
away from your current policy and so
this would say if you want to be really
sure that your new value is better than
your old value then just take a very
small step size and intuitively it's
because if you change your policy very
very small amounts at least under some
smoothness guarantees the value of your
policy can't change that much it should
also be intuitive that like your
gradient is often a pretty good estimate
very close to your current value of your
function but we also need to quickly try
to get to a good policy so this is not
generally practical and so the idea of
sort of trp oh one of the main ideas is
to think of there being kind of a
trusted region and use this to constrain
our step sizes so again if we go back to
sort of the generic template for policy
gradient algorithms we have to make this
choice of how far out to step in our
gradient and the idea is we're going to
define a constraint so we're gonna have
our objective
function here and instead of explicitly
subtracting off our lower bound we're
just gonna say you can move you can
change your gradient but not too far I'm
gonna put a constraint on how far the KL
divergence can be as a ways to sort of
say you're kind of having this region of
which and you're in your parameter space
that allows you to know how far you can
change your policy okay so I'm just
gonna talk very briefly about how this
is instantiated so the main idea is that
if we look at what these objective
functions are this may or may not be
easy for us to evaluate so if we look
back at what Thetas even here right we
have sort of our discounted visitation
weights under the current policy we
don't have direct access to that we have
only access to samples from really not a
current policy so the first idea is that
instead of taking an explicit sum over
the state space where that state space
might be you know continuous and
infinite we're just gonna look at the
states that were actually sampled by our
current old policy and reweighed them so
that's the first two part the the first
substitution we do what we're trying to
do right now is say we have this
objective function and we want to make
it so that this can be part of an
algorithm but we can compute all the
quantities we need to in order to take a
step size where we think the new policy
is going to be better the second thing
we do and this relates to Andrews
question about importance sampling is we
have this second quantity in here where
this is the probability of an action
under our new policy we do have access
to that in the sense that if someone
gives us a state we can tell we can say
exactly what our probability would be
under all the actions but again this
often can be a continuous set and so
instead of doing sort of this continuous
that we're just going to say we're going
to use importance sampling and we can
take samples this is typically going to
be from PI old so we look at where times
where we've taken an action given our
current policy weary weight them
according to the probability we would
have taken those actions under our new
policy so that allows us to approximate
that expectation using
that we have and then the third
substitution is switching the advantage
back to the q function and it's just
important to note that all of these
three substitutions don't change the
solution to the objective to the
optimization problem these are all sort
of taking these different substitutions
are different ways to evaluate these
quantities so we end up with the
following um we have this objective
function that were optimizing this is
after we've done the substitutions I
just mentioned and we have this
constraint on how far away we can be and
empirically they generally just sample
the sort of alternative sampling
distribution q is just your existing old
policy so there's a bunch of other stuff
in the paper it's a really nice paper a
lot of really interesting ideas I I'll
just I'll skip through sort of exactly
how they do some of the additional
details there's some nice complexity
there but I'll just say briefly the main
thing they're doing here is they're
running a policy they're computing this
gradient they have to consider these
constraints and they do the serve line
search with a Kail constraint and
perhaps the most important thing is just
to be aware of this and to sort of
understand kind of them being inspired
by this conservative policy improvement
and then trying to make that more
practical and fast um they've applied it
to a lot of different problems there's
some really nice stuff on locomotion
controllers cases where you have
continuous action spaces continuous
state spaces these are cases where
policy gradient is often very helpful I
and they have some very nice results I
will step through those here the main
thing to know is that empirically this
is a really good tool to know about
often if you're doing policy gradient
style approaches ERP ou can be a very
useful thing to build on and it's been
incredibly influential this was came out
and I CML in 2015 there's hundreds of
citations to it already
so this is sort of become one of the
main benchmarks for policy gradient okay
so if we go back just to kind of what
the to summarize what the policy
gradient algorithm template is whether
you're looking at the existing
algorithms or whether you're trying to
define your own generally they look like
something in like the following for each
iteration you run your policy out and
gather true
victories of data by running that policy
you compute some target that might be
just the rewards that might be a cue
function we can trade off between bias
and variance and that and then we use
that to estimate the policy gradient and
then we may want to smartly take a step
along that gradient to try to ensure
monotonic improvement the things to be
aware of and some of the things you're
gonna have practice on soon is that you
should be very familiar with these sort
of vanilla approaches and reinforce and
this general template sort of understand
how some of the different algorithms
we're talking about might instantiate
these different things you don't have to
derive and remember all the formula that
I just went through quickly forty RPO
and you'll have the opportunity to
practice these more in homework 3 but
we're only cover these lightly in terms
of the midterm all right Susan maybe
have any questions about this before we
go into sort of a short overview of the
stuff we've done so far for before the
midterm okay all right let's switch over
okay so what this is gonna be is sort of
a very short recap of what we've done so
far and in terms of why this is useful
there's certainly a lot of good evidence
from learning sciences that spaced
repetition of ideas is really helpful as
is forced recall which is one of the
other benefits of doing exams and so
that's what we're gonna do today is just
sort of do a quick recap of a lot of the
different main ideas so again
reinforcement learning generally
involves optimization delayed
consequences generalization and
exploration we haven't really talked
about that yet so that's not really
gonna be on the midterm we're gonna
start talking a lot more about that post
the midterm it's an incredibly important
topic what I think is super fascinating
and one of the main reasons why RL is
interesting but these other things are
really important too and we spent some
time on those so far so in terms of
thinking about the midterm and indeed
thinking about the class on the very
first day I put up this sort of Blizzard
of learning objectives and I just want
to highlight a few of these which are
the things that are I mentioned we're
gonna be explicitly evaluated in the
exam which is that
by the end of the class including on the
exam you should be very familiar with
sort of what are the key features of
reinforcement learning that make it
different than other machine learning
problems and other AI problems so we
spent some time on that in the first day
and I've sort of tried to talk about it
throughout but the fact that the agent
is collecting its own data and that the
data it gathers influences the policies
it can learn so we sort of have this
sensor data issue the agent can't know
about other lives that didn't Lee didn't
live makes a very big difference
compared to supervised learning a second
really important thing is that if you
are given an application problem it's
important to try to know why I or why
not to formally formulate it as a
reinforcement learning problem and if so
how you would generally there's not a
single answer to this so it's good to
think of like what is one or more way to
define the state space the actions base
the dynamics and the reward model and
what algorithm you would suggest from
class to try to tackle it this is in
general sort of something that you'll
probably run into much more than like
looking at any particular algorithm
particularly in industry and then a
third thing that I think is really
important is to understand how we decide
whether or not an RL algorithm is good
and so what is the criteria for
performance an evaluation we can use to
sort of evaluate what are the benefits
strengths and weaknesses of different
algorithms and how they compare so this
could be things like bias and variance
it also could be computational
complexity or sample efficiency or other
aspects so what we've covered so far is
planning where we know how the world
works policy evaluation model free
learning how to make good decisions
value function approximation and then
imitation learning a policy search and
we've also talked about the fact that
for reinforcement learning in general
you can think of either trying to find a
value function of policy or a model and
that a model is sufficient to generate a
value function which is sufficient to
generate a policy but they're not all
necessary you don't have to have a model
in order to get a policy so
I'll go through this part pretty fast
since I think a lot of you guys have
also seen some of this stuff in previous
classes so we're almost everything we've
been talking about so far assumes the
world is a Markov decision process that
I've mentioned that often the world is
not a Markov decision process and in the
MDP case we assume that the the state is
sufficient I'm a sufficient statistic of
all the prior history so we don't have
to keep track of the full set of states
and observations and actions rewards
from the whole time period but we can
just look at the current observation in
order to make good decisions in the
world in terms of this it's very useful
to know what the Markov property is why
it's important why it might be violated
what are things like models value
functions and queues and what is
planning and what is the difference some
planning we assume that you're given a
model of how the world works you know
the dynamics model you know the reward
model it still can be really hard to
figure out how to act this is like
knowing the game of go it's still really
really computationally intensive and
tricky to try to figure out what's the
optimal decision to take and go even
though you know all the dynamics and all
the rewards in learning we don't know
the dynamics and rewards and we still
have to gather data in order to learn a
good policy which has a high value a
high discounted expected some of the
awards we talked about the bellman
back-up operator which is a contraction
if your discount factor is less than 1
which means those repeated applications
you're guaranteed to converge to a
single fixed point we talked about value
versus policy iteration in value
iteration on the iteration K you are
always computing the optimal value as if
you only get to make K decisions and
then you use that to back up and get the
K plus 1
policy policy iteration you always have
a policy and the value of that policy if
you were to act using it forever but it
might not be a very good policy and then
you update this and as we've seen it's
closely related to sort of policy
gradient style algorithms where we sort
of try to estimate the gradient of a
policy so in policy iteration generally
and similar to what we've been seeing in
policy grading approaches we intermix
evaluation and
but so we can be the value of a policy
and then we use that in order to take a
step and improve it if we are in the
case of being model free and not having
access to a model we often want to
compute Q values instead so that we can
directly improve the policy so let's
just take a quick second so these are
check your understandings or good things
to go back through these are all sort of
like you know some small conceptual
questions of the type that we might ask
you on the exam so let's just take a
minute and to check our understanding
and think about for a finite state
action MDP the lookup table
representation which means that we just
have a table entry for each state in
action gamma less than 1 does the
initial studying of the value function
impact the final computed values why or
why not does value iteration and policy
iteration always yield the same solution
and is the number of iterations needed
for Pali policy iteration in a finite
state an action MDP bounded and if so
how many let me just take a minute and
think about those feel free to talk to
somebody next to you
all right we're gonna vote so um I'm
gonna ask who thinks that the initial
setting of value of the value function
does not matter great yes it does not
matter and it doesn't matter so no
doesn't matter and why not because
there's only a single fixed point
because it's like the bellmen operator
is a contraction all right how about who
thinks the value iteration and Policy
iteration always yield the same solution
yes
no exactly yeah so what that is correct
you're gonna get the same value function
so it depends which way you're trying to
answer this they're gonna have the same
value they could have different policies
and that's possible if there's more than
one policy that has the same optimal
value that can come up because often
there's multiple policies where you're
splitting ties who thinks that the
number of iterations need for policy
duration is bounded that's right
everyone tell me how many it is the
that's the total number of policies in
policy iteration in tabular MDPs with
like policy improvement in tabular mdps
you're guaranteed to be monotonically
improving so you couldn't most go
through every policy once and then
you're done so it sort of relates to
what we were just talking about in that
case you definitely get guaranteed
policy improvement because every there's
no function approximation there there's
no errors you exactly know what the
current value is and then you can take a
monotonic improvement step all right so
now we're going to talk briefly of a
refresher on model-free policy
evaluation so this is model free policy
evaluation was this sort of passive
reinforcement learning
um where we're just trying to understand
how good an existing policy is ideally
with not too much data
and so we want to either directly
estimate the cue function or the value
function of the policy and so we talked
mostly in this case about episodic
domains
when I say episodic domains I mean that
we're gonna act in the world for a fixed
number of steps or where we're in a
setting where we know we have terminal
States so we know the episodes will end
the probability one they have to end and
then at that point you're reset to a
start state with some fixed distribution
and in Monte Carlo approaches we
directly average the episodic rewards
it's pretty simple we take our existing
policy we run it out for H steps or
until the end of the episode we reset we
repeat that a whole bunch of times and
we just average but in TV learning or
key learning we use a target to
bootstrap and I know you guys have seen
this a number of times but just as a
refresher and I like these diagrams just
to think about the distinctions so we've
talked about dynamic programming here
we've thought about the case where we
know the transition model we know the
reward model so when we think about what
the value is of a policy it's exactly
equal to the expected distribution of
states and actions we would encounter by
following this policy of the reward we
would get plus gamma times the value of
the next state so note that when we
think about this expectation here
there's really an S prime so that
expectation is thinking about all the
next states that we might get to and so
in dynamic programming we just
explicitly think about that sum that sum
over all the next states we much reach
might reach and the value of each of
those states so if we had started in
this state we take an action we get to
some next new States in general we could
repeat this process all the way out till
we reach you know the horizon H or
terminal States and there's what we
think of here is taking an expectation
over the next states that we would reach
and what we do in dynamic programming is
instead bootstrap so what we mean by
bootstrap here
is that instead of building this whole
tree we keep track of what the value is
of all the states and we use that to
take an explicit expectation over the
next States we reach an average over the
value of those next states and note that
in this case we're assuming we know the
model now there are ways to extend this
where we don't know the model but we
haven't talked very much about those
this term so but we're nice a dynamic
programming here I mean that unless we
otherwise specify that we know the
models of the world so this is a case
where we're bootstrapping because we are
update is using v4v use as an estimate
okay because those values are not going
to be perfect estimates that the true
expected discounted reward for those
next States because we're still
computing them then we looked at Monte
Carlo policy evaluation and it looks
pretty similar in many ways except for
what we're doing is we are writing a
trajectory all the way out to the
horizon we're adding up all the rewards
and that is our target and when we say
that policy evaluation with Monte Carlo
is sampling it means we're sampling the
Richard what is the expectation that
we're approximating we're expectation
approximately an expectation over that
probability of s prime so we only got a
single s prime instead of getting an
expectation over all the next ones and
the problem with that is that we said it
was high variance even though it was
unbiased and then we talked about
combining these ideas with temporal
difference methods where we're both
going to bootstrap and sample so we're
sampling because we are only looking at
a single next state and we are
bootstrapping because we are plugging in
our estimate of V so we're sampling a
single s T plus 1 and we're
bootstrapping because we're not rolling
all the way out like we did with Monte
Carlo we're just plugging in our current
estimate of that value function so let's
do another quick understanding of for
each of these cases it's good to know
whether it with whether it applies to
dynamic programming which requires you
to know the models of Monte Carlo or TD
learning so is it usable when we don't
know the models of the current
does it handle continue it continuing
non episodic domains does it handle non
Markovian domains let me be clear by
that clear what I mean by that you can
always apply any algorithm to anything
it just may give you garbage out and so
my question is when you when I say
handling non Markovian domains is it
guaranteed to do something good or does
it probably fundamentally make a Markov
assumption does it converge to the true
value of the policy and the limit of
updates right now we're thinking about
tabular case so the value function is
exactly representable and is it giving
us an unbiased estimate of the value
along the way faster mid still might be
consistent which means that eventually
with enough data they converge to the
right thing but they could give you
biased estimates along the way so again
let's just spend like a minute or two
and the ad is they're just binary
answers to each of these so yes or no
for each of them feel free to talk to
somebody next
it's a great question quality iteration
all right and ask people to vote again
okay so I'll just ask you to raise your
hands if the answer is yes
so is DP is dynamic programming usable
when there are no models of the current
domain no is monte-carlo usable yes the
TD usable great okay does DP handle
continuing non episodic domains raise
your hand up yes correct
yep so you can use dynamic programming
you can use Billman operators and
contractions even if the you know for
infinite horizon domains you generally
want your gamma function to be less than
one so your values don't explode but you
can do it
what about Monte Carlo estimates no
right Monte Carlo only updates when you
get to the end of an episode TV
estimates yes
great does DP handle non Markovian
domains no does Monte Carlo guess TV
again you can run all of these things
wherever you want but yes um converges
to the true value of the policy in the
limit of updates for DP yes Monte Carlo
yes TD yes
unbiased estimate of the value DP it's
kind of not applicable because we're not
really using data it's sort of a little
bit different Monte Carlo is it an
unbiased estimate of the value yes TD no
great so and if we're asking you about
this in the exam we'd be sure to clarify
whether we're talking about the tabular
setting or the function approximation
setting where everything can be very
different
yes the white tea doesn't work
oh yes yeah there's a good one so why
does he do not work for Markovian um
it's because it's fundamentally making a
Markov assumption about the domain and
the reason that comes up is here so the
way it is writing down the value
function is it saying that the expected
just kind of sum of rewards from the
current state is exactly equal to the
immediate reward plus the discounted
future sum of rewards for each of the
next states where that's encapsulated
only by s T plus 1 so that is where
you're making the Markovian assumption
because your alias see if if you have an
observation space which was aliased that
would ignore the whole history whereas
Monte Carlo is summing up all the
rewards from that current state onwards
great question emmmm yuning
very good so saying we talked to almost
everything we've been talking about it's
td0 where we just have this reward plus
gamma at times the value function but we
also talked briefly about n step where
you sort of would do r1 plus r2 plus
gamma times r2 etc so for the N step
you'd have something like this you'd
have RT plus gamma RT plus 1 plus gamma
squared RT plus 2 plus gamma cubed V of
s T plus 3 so that would be like an N
step and that is essentially making
different notions of Markovian
assumptions because you can have
Continuum's you can either have
completely non Markovian domains or we
can have things like n step Markov
domains which essentially means that if
you're making a keeping track of a
certain amount of history so just to
sort of give an example that similar to
some of the ones that we've seen before
we could think of something like a
random walk process so imagine that we
have a domain where we have three states
and two terminal States so we always
start in state B and then with
probability 50% we go left or right and
if you reached either of the black nodes
then the process terminates and when you
get there either you get plus one on
this one or you get zero and it's a
random walk with equal probability until
you get to a terminal state and then the
process ends and so in this case we
could try to compute like what is the
true value of a state so the true value
of a state in this case would involve us
thinking about what is the distribution
of states that you would visit under
this random walk process so for example
if we think about what the value is of
I'll do this so if you think about what
the value is of state C that's always
going to be equal to the immediate word
plus gamma times the sum over the next
States
value a best prime well let's call this
one like I know SD on this one s zero so
s DS value it's always going to be
cooled up plus one so V of SD is equal
to plus one because you get that reward
and then it terminates so this would say
with gamma times half probability you
would go to the value of SB that's DB
plus half you get one and eventually if
you look at this distribution that's
going to be C you could do this process
for each of the different states what
you would find when you do this is that
you get through this random walk
terminating on the right side or the
left side in terms of the probability
distribution and you could compute the
values for this in the exam we would
probably make this a little bit easier
but it's good to be able to sort of look
at this example and work through it and
see what this part would be in terms of
the value function then the next
question is let's imagine that we have a
particular trajectory we want to compare
what would happen under different
algorithms so let's imagine what we have
is we have a trajectory where we go b CB
c-terminal plus 1 so that's our episode
so what is the first visit Monte Carlo
estimate of B what that's right so so V
of B is equal to 1 why is that because
what we do in Monte Carlo is we add up
for purses at Monte calorie we look at
the first time we visit a state and we
add up all the rewards we get from that
state till the end of the episode in
this case that rewards just 1 so the
estimate of this would be 1 the only
other exception you know thing that we
might want to know about there is if
you're doing sort of this sliding
average like an alpha estimate to update
the Monte Carlo estimate you'd want to
know what the initial values were and
what alpha was but let's imagine that
here you just look at exactly taking
that return so this is equal to the
return starting at B go
to the end of the episode so then the
next question is what are the TD
learning updates given the data in this
order c-terminal + 1 vc 0 CB 0 with a
learning rate of a maybe just take like
a minute or two and do one or two of
these updates and then think about what
would happen if we reverse the order of
the data with the same learning rate so
this really it's to a point we've talked
about a couple times about whether or
not the order of updates we do given
some set of data matters in terms of the
values we compute so I guess I would go
at this in the following way I would
first convince yourself either way
whether or not the order matters in
terms of the values we're going to
compute and then try to compute one or
two of them so let's just spend like a
minute or two to decide whether or not
the order matters here in terms of the
resulting values and then we can also
compute
and I know I'm not giving you guys
enough time to do all the computations
here but this is mostly just sort of do
that forced recall aspect of trying to
remember exactly what the formulas are
and remember whether or not this matters
so I'm just gonna ask you to vote um who
here thinks that the order matters in
terms of some of the values we compute
that's right no it won't always
sometimes do you can do things in
different orders at the fact that we've
emphasized a lot might lead you to
believe that it always matters it
doesn't always matter but in this case
it does so in this case if we look at
what the value is in the first order
what we would do is we'd say B of C is
equal to 0 plus alpha 1 minus 0 so the
new reward Weavers observed that would
be alpha then when we're computing the
value of b we could use the new b of c
we just computed because when we have
this update now we've already got a
nonzero estimate for B is C note to be
precise I should have told you here
exactly how we're initializing all the
values so in this case we've implicitly
assumed that the initial values are 0
this matters a lot we'll talk some more
in a week or two about smarter
exploration and the fact that being
optimistic often really is very helpful
one challenge can be in deep neural
networks is how to set things so that
they're optimistic but in this case so
we're assuming that everything is zero
so via B will be alpha squared B of C
will be the following expression these
are basically me just applying TV
learning these cases there
in the second line yeah good catch in
the we're going off squid yeah yes yeah
that final expression Thanks
so which reappears in the third line if
we do it in the reverse order V of C
will be zero for our first update
because C goes to B B at V of B is zero
then when we update BC zero the value of
C is still zero and we only update V of
C in the final way so this just points
out that order matters this comes up
also when we're doing function
approximation and episodic replay just
in general we think about policy
evaluation algorithms it's good to be
aware the bias-variance tradeoff data
efficiency and computational efficiency
TD learning tends to be pretty good on
computational efficiency data efficiency
wise it depends a little bit sometimes
if you do experience replay with TD it
gets better so it's useful to think
about there's often a lot of variants of
these algorithms and so just being
precise and whatever your whatever
you're stating if you just assuming the
vanilla version we're using or if you're
like well if you do this additional
experience replay this is how it can
change okay
now let's think about how we can do
model free learning to make good
decisions we've talked a lot about Q
learning Q learning is a bootstrapping
technique that assumes Markovian a
Markovian world we say that the value
the Q value is going to be approximated
by the reward plus gamma times max over
a prime with the next Q function and we
can use that as sort of our target and
then we do the slow slowing we're sort
of have this updated learning rate it's
not learning rate where we're slowing
between the one-sample we just saw
versus our previous estimate when we
slowly slew this towards we generally
decrease alpha over time to try to
converge Q to a single value I
we talked about some conditions under
which for q-learning to converge again
this is all under sort of well this is
both under reach ability assumptions and
also or right now we're talking about
the tabular setting so there's no
function approximation going on so if
you act randomly q-learning will
converge to Q star under mild reach
ability assumptions which means that you
know you can't have a helicopter which
if you crash it the world is over and
you can't get any more samples so you
have to be able to sort of repeatedly
visit all the states the intimate number
of times and try all of the actions an
infinite number of times and it has this
interesting property that when you're
doing Q learning you can use data
gathered by one policy to estimate the
value of another policy so this is we're
trying to estimate the optimal Q
function but we can use for example
random data random samples a random
policy to try to estimate that and the
reason for that is because we're doing
this max we're always looking at what's
the best thing we could do next so
that's a pretty cool property so then if
we sort of think about in this case
there's a some different things we'll go
through these I guess just briefly I if
you have a Q learning policy which has a
greedy be greedy here is with
probability one minus Epsilon you take
the action which is expected to be best
under your current Q function and with
probability epsilon you act randomly so
if you're in a lookup table this is
guaranteed to converge to the optimal
policy in the limit of infinite data so
this is yes with mild reach ability for
this second one can we use Monte Carlo
estimation in mdps with large state
spaces let's vote of yes
what everyone take a second then just
talk to your neighbor then we'll vote
again I'm not saying that those people
are wrong I'm just saying that since
most people didn't vote I'm assuming
that most people would benefit from just
thinking about for a sec all right let's
vote again I vote if you think Monte
Carlo estimation can be used in mdps
with large state spaces yes yeah so it's
not it's not you're not restricted to
whether it's a large state space or not
you can use much color estimation there
I that that's so I guess it can so no
Monte Carlo can be used
yes
great question so I Monte Carlo if you
there are a number of data points per
state could be very low if you have a
single start state that's not too bad if
you have a distribution of start states
can be trickier or we're gonna want to
move into the value function
approximation setting but there's
nothing a priori which means you can't
apply it like you put in there it might
be really bad you might need to start
doing function approximation the last
thing I put on there this is something
that's we haven't discussed a lot yet I
think it's an interesting thing to start
for one to sort of start connecting
these between the dynamic programming
aspects we've talked about model-based
reinforcement learning is not
necessarily always more data efficient
than
all free though we talked mostly about
model free and so we haven't discussed
this too much but well it's a good thing
to be thinking about particularly as we
start getting into exploration and I
mentioned briefly before that there's a
nice new paper by when Sun and some
colleagues at MSR Microsoft Research New
York City that is showing that in some
cases model-based is strictly better
than model free and the intuition there
is that you couldn't compactly represent
the model but you can't compactly
represent the value function so you
don't need a lot of parameters to learn
the model and then you can plan with it
but if you try to directly learn the
value function you need a lot more all
right so as we're sort of starting to
move into and even just in that
discussion a lot of our recent focus has
been in value function approximation I'm
including in homework 2 so we talked
about if you were looking at Monte Carlo
methods versus TD learning what sort of
convergence guarantees do we have in the
on policy case so this is important to
emphasize so we're looking at evaluating
the value of a single policy and we
talked about how we could think about
the on policy stationary distribution
that when we define a single policy then
and we run it that's like we're inducing
a Markov reward process or a Markov
chain and we think can think about the
stationary distribution of states that
we would visit under that policy and we
talked about convergence properties and
in particular we said that what Monte
Carlo does no matter what sort of
function approximator you're using is it
tries to minimize the mean squared error
so the style of techniques we've talked
about with Monte Carlo is that it simply
tries to minimize the mean squared error
of your data and so we could think about
this for a linear value function
approximation this also holds for other
value function approximation
mater's it's going to minimize there in
the case of linear value function
approximation with TD Lerner learning
it's can I converge to a constant vector
of the best mean squared error now what
does that mean in this case here what we
have is we might have a gap so
particularly if you have something like
linear value function of R
mater's you just might not be able to
write to exactly represent the value of
all the states use the the chosen like
parametric family that you have and so
there might fundamentally just be a gap
between the value function that's
representable with the space that you
have and the true value function i would
like to think about like this there's a
nice picture inside know partially about
this too this is sort of a showing with
your set of w what are the value
functions you can represent and it might
be that your variable value function
lives up here you just can't with for
example with a line be able to represent
all of the true value functions if you
think about this into DeMint and another
dimension you can imagine for a state
may be your real value function looks
something like this but you were using a
line approximator
so you just can't represent that exactly
yeah a straight line so Monte Carlo
converges to the best mean squared error
possible given your value function of
parks mater space and TD Lerner
converges to that times its additional
factor I think that's not kind of like
that okay so note that there's this
well no I'm just gonna make that not
deal anywhere act
we talked about the fact that when
you're doing off policy learning
q-learning with function approximation
can diverge which means that doesn't
even converge with infinite amounts of
data this has even separate than what it
might converge to if it converges it
just says that the actual your
parameters just may never stop changing
if you're doing sort of grading updates
limitations whether or not the
initialization of the parameters helps
determine whether or not for example you
might converge or diverge it's an
interesting question I don't think
there's work that I know if it formally
tries to characterize this like you know
are there places where you could
formally do this so that in terms of
your ingredients for example they
wouldn't start to explode there might be
I suspect it depends a lot on the
problem and I also suspect that there
might be pathological examples you can
construct where it's hard to do but
certainly worth the try you can also
observe whether your parameter estimates
are continuing to change um we talked
quite a lot of you guys had a lot of
practice with deep learning a model
freaky learning um where we looked at
having this cue learning target in the Q
Network and we're doing stochastic
gradient descent we're using a deep
neural network to approximate Q we
talked about that some of the challenges
with the sort of divergence might be
that we have these sort of correlated
local updates the value of a state is
often very closely related to the value
of its next successor state and that
also by changing these targets
frequently then that might caused
instability so that sort of a lot of the
recent progress over roughly the last
five years has been in sort of ways to
modify this equation in order to make it
more stable when you're doing gradient
descent and in dqn it's sort of both
introduced that we should do experience
replay so don't use each data point once
and also fix the target for awhile so
you're sort of saying I'm gonna use this
a fixed value function approximator of
my next state for a while and then we
can minimize our mean squared error we
talked about the fact that experienced
replay is particularly hugely helpful
and the targets is also quite
and there aren't good guarantees yet on
convergence though there's a lot of
interesting work that's being done in
this space people were very interested
in trying to understand the formal
properties of these types of networks we
also talked about double Q dueling and
like prioritize we play as things that
we could look at to try to improve how
quickly our key functions converge to
something reasonable so I think this is
the last one for today so quick question
I mean finite state spaces with features
that can represent the true value
function does TD learning with value
function approximation always find the
true value function of the policy given
sufficient data so this is for TD
learning so we're essentially doing
policy evaluation right now so in this
case are we guaranteed to find the true
value function given sufficient data
maybe take one chat with the neighbor
for one minute and then I'll ask people
to vote seumas's on policy or at least
with sufficient amounts of data from the
on policy distribution
[Music]
all right who wants to vote yes that we
do find the true value function
approximator right okay so how could we
have checked this so if we go back to
what I was saying
over here what I said is that we're
going to converge to a constant factor
of the best mean squared error this mean
squared error is always zero if you can
exactly represent the value in the
current space so that additional sort of
constant factor is just a constant
factor times zero so in this case yes
so I because I said here that it with
features that can represent the true
value function so we've said that it is
perfectly possible to represent the
value function of this policy in the
features I'd given to you and so it will
be possible to achieve that yeah so true
for a nonlinear amortization for tt'
learning yeah
so for Policy evaluation if you have a
nonlinear if you have features like if
you have a general representation that
allows you to exactly represent the
value of function and you're doing on
policy learning so you're doing TD
learning you will be able to get 0 with
infinite you know sufficient data
etcetera finite data this is all up yeah
hey I got a little confused given that
they might have all the features that we
want but we might not have any
representative value function
approximation that would actually be
able to generate a cute pic are doing
two things like identical ladies I guess
the way I was thinking about this would
be might have all the features but we
might not find the space of functions
that actually would be able to represent
the value function okay so I think
questions say okay well what if we had a
lot of features but like it does that
actually give us a parameterization of
the value function that it can represent
the true value question when I say here
sort of features and representation I
mean that we have picked a function
class that can exactly represent the
value function if we have an algorithm
to try to fit it well it up so what I'm
assuming it what I'm saying in this case
is that if your value function if
someone could if an Oracle could give
you those features the parameter vector
that would make that zero that TD
learning can find it
because we can generate the table qubit
you don't have to be tabular so to go to
really does not have to only hold for
tabular cases it's that if like so if we
look at something here let's imagine
this is your state space this is your
value function so if someone gives you a
line or a quadratic or a deep neural
network with enough parameters to
exactly represent that line what this
statement is saying is that TV learning
can find can fit those parameters
exactly this is not true when we start
to go into cue learning so in some cases
you can have a representation that could
optimally represent the value function
but you can't find it like q-learning
will not identify it so that's sort of
the difference that we're trying to make
here is that a TV learning if that
exists in your on policy you can find it
cue learning you may not be able to the
others a question in back in named purse
please
yeah so what's professional is its
Israel this is true for generic
representations if your representation
whether it's linear tabular or topical
you're generally always assumed it's
exact so linear or otherwise then then
this is this is true yes
does this have anything to do with if
our value function proximity is a
contracting operator or not so yeah it's
a goodness yes whether or not this has
to do with whether or not our value
function approximator is a contraction
you can think of when we're doing this
sort of TD learning that we have two
steps we're kind of doing our
approximated bellman and our bellman
operator if we could do it exactly we
know as a contraction and then we have
to do this additional part of fitting a
function and if you can exactly fit your
function then you're not gonna introduce
additional error during that part so
that's one of that's one of the benefits
in here that could not that can start to
be different so in this case again it's
all on policy so it's much closer the
supervised learning setting when you
start to be off policy this gets more
complicated
all right so let's just go really
briefly through imitation learning and
policy search this will be kind of at
the same later level that you'd be
expected to know it for the exam you
haven't had a chance to practice either
of these except for a from lecture so
imitation learning was the idea that the
specification of reward functions can be
really complicated what if we could just
have people demonstrate procedures and
then learn from them behavior coding is
where we're doing supervised learning so
we're trying to learn a mapping of
actions to states and we're treating
this as a supervised learning problem so
we just look at for an expert pairs of
states and action and you can try to fit
your favorite Michigan learning
supervised classification algorithm to
predict that and the thing that can go
wrong in this case is that your state
distribution that you induce under your
approximate policy it's trying to mimic
the expert could be different than the
distribution of states you'd reach under
the expert policy which means that you
can end up with these sort of different
state distributions and you don't know
what the right thing is to do under
these new states because you'll have any
data about that so things can go pretty
badly in some of those cases we talked
about imitation learning where the idea
is that we have again trajectories of
demonstrations and now the goal is to
directly learn rewards
a good thing to rethink about here is
how many reward functions are compatible
with an expert's demonstration we talked
about this before if it's not clear feel
free to reach out to me either at the
end of class or on Piazza and then we
talked about policy search so just
really briefly these are the types of
levels of questions I would expect you
to be familiar with so why do we want to
do stochastic parametrize policies it
can be a nice way to put in domain
knowledge it can help us with non
Markovian structure we talked about
aliasing and we talked about game theory
settings where deterministic policies
would do badly but stochastic ones would
do well Policy crenate weapons are not
the only form of policy search we talked
about exoskeleton optimization by my
colleague Steve culling and the fact
that that worked pretty well but
generally were going to talk mostly
about gradients the likelihood ratio
policy grading method does not need us
to have the dynamics model which is
really important because when we don't
have it and then two ideas to reduce the
variance of a policy gradient estimator
is to use the temporal structure and
here it involves the fact that the
reward you get at a time step now can't
be influenced by your future decisions
because of the structure of time and
then and secondly baselines so that's
kind of the level that sort of this
stuff we talked about in class but not
deep procedural knowledge so just to
summarize recommendations would be to go
through lecture notes look at things
like check your understanding if you
want to look at existing additional
examples going through session notes can
be useful the practice midterm is
particularly last year will be more
similar to the one from two years ago
if you see some topic that we haven't
covered in this class it's not going to
be covered on the midterm but feel free
to reach out to us if you have any
questions and you can bring a one-sided
one page of notes that's handwritten or
typed okay good luck
you